[Music]
prince harry and his wife megan are in
new york city this morning and yesterday
the couple toured the world trade center
site including the observatory at one
world trade and the september 11th
memorial it's all part of a visit that
includes this weekend's global citizen
festival and our nicki batista has more
on that
a smiling meghan markle returned to new
york city thursday her first visit
accompanied by husband prince harry and
the couple's first trip outside of
california since the birth of their
daughter in june global citizen live
from new york they're in town for global
citizen live a 24-hour charity concert
in new york central park in more than
eight other major cities it's a call for
unity for global access to covet
vaccines and to fight climate change and
world hunger with the help of political
leaders and artists including billy
eilish ed sheeran and her
back in may harry and megan were
campaign chairs for the organization's
vax live another concert aimed at
pandemic recovery as long as nations
struggle with kobit 19
we all struggle with it certainly harry
and megan realize they have a unique
platform in that they have access into
the sort of the world of global
political leaders as well as global
celebrity leaders and they're able to
take advantage of influence in both of
those arenas on thursday they met with
the u.s ambassador to the united nations
and partnered with the world health
organization in a round table with
global health leaders and public health
officials on vaccine equity we know that
their two children archie harrison and
lilly diana were left back in california
for this very important trip so we know
they're going to you know figure out
ways to pursue the causes that are
important to them and also make sure the
kids are taking care of it and have that
family life as well for cbs mornings i'm
nikki batiste in new york
i think it's great to have them in new
york people are very excited to see them
here and they want to use their platform
for good so welcome megan that's it we
love when influential figures stamp
their name on something especially this
and we get good music too yeah they walk
the walk and talk to talk and good music
yeah and good music it's always a good
way to end it